[Music]
I think there are more problems with
gravity and also general relativity in
particular so we need a new theory to
describe the phenomena that we are
observing gravity works well but you
should understand that has a lot of ways
it really works well unless we
understand dark energy and the
gravitational force associated with it
we will complete it with our universal
no after this will crunch into a black
hole type all will just continue and
smooth expansion forever
[Music]
so why is a force that's so central to
the universe and our science so elusive
in its character on my right we have
Eric valinda who's Utrecht theoretical
physicist and string theorist um on my
left Frank will check theoretical
physicist and Nobel laureate at MIT and
Laura Messina halton professor of
physics at the University of North
Carolina and her work focuses on
cosmology and the birth of universities
from the multiverse so if I could I
think Eric would you would you stop and
tell us why you think gravity is so
elusive
gravity exists I mean indeed if we can
keep our feet on the ground and we sit
in our chairs thanks to gravity but what
is it it mean is it the fundamental
force that we need to assume right from
the beginning and then describe it or is
it possible to derive it without
assuming it mean derive it really from
something underlying from the
microscopic I'm saying on a say the
letter
it's our current theory of gravity which
is general relativity is it really the
correct theory I mean can we describe
everything we can observe even with it
or is it only the problem with the
Planck scale I think there are more
problems with gravity and also general
relativity in particular so we need a
new theory to describe the phenomena
that we are even observing and
particularly in cosmology but let me
start out by saying that general
relativity is very successful and is a
beautiful theory and there are many
things that have been tested I mean the
gravity waves is certainly one of the
recent successes but it doesn't mean
that all predictions that we that are
made by general relativity are correct
and I want to mention a few that are
troublesome first of all our mentioned
quantum mechanics but also there's a
problem with the value of the vacuum
energy the cosmological constant which
also has to do with quantum mechanics
then there is a black hole I mean black
holes are our elusive objects where
there are many puzzles in particular
about the information that goes in and a
thing people are probably generally
agree that we haven't really solved
those puzzles but what for me actually
even stands out is that there are even
observations that are not in agreement
with general relativity if we look at
galaxies we see that the way the gal at
the stars are moving in galaxies cannot
be explained by simply assuming general
relativity namely the stars are moving
much too fast the only way we can
explain it and save the series by
assuming that there is an additional
amount of matter that we have not
observed yet which we call dark matter
but this is a safe way of saving it
which is assuming that general
relativity is correct and the reason is
that we don't see
why it should be wrong there's no
conceptual reason why that should be the
case now that brings me to the puzzles
of black holes I mean if you think about
black holes and the way to behave
they actually are are teaching us the
actually laboratory stress there are the
thought experiments which teaches that
the equations of gravity look like those
of thermodynamics
the laws that describe heat and
temperature and so on and those who know
we can derive from something microscopic
by treating statistically the
microscopic molecules while the same is
true for gravity the general relativity
equations can be derived from something
microscopic and that's the kind of
theory I'm working on is precisely
describing what is the analog of atoms
of space-time that we have to assume and
there we go into the quantum phenomena
of space-time and there's a microscopic
picture of space-time from which you can
derive gravity and then you can actually
also explain the phenomena that we are
observing in galaxies without even
assuming the dark matter
well I think gravity is elusive because
no convincing experimental evidence that
gets beyond general relativity has been
found nor is there any prospect of any
the people who set out to detect
gravitational waves started 50 years ago
estimating what it would take the estin
to detect gravitational waves from for
instance black holes merging and they
estimated that they would have to set up
some mirrors to detect Ripa the warping
of space-time which is what a
gravitational wave is that would be able
to detect motions of these mirrors that
are of the size of a thousandth of a
nucleus thousandth of the size not of an
atom but of an atomic nucleus was a
hundred thousand times smaller over a
distance of four kilometers so when the
mirrors of four kilometers away you have
to detect that kind of change and by
golly they took 50 years and surmount
the difficulty after difficulty and
there it was so that's a pretty
impressive theory it may need changes
there are indications that the equations
become singular and very very extreme
condition is like it at the center of
black holes or in the extremely
extremely extremely early moments of the
Big Bang but it's easy to say gravity
works well and but you should understand
that has a lot of weight
it really works well under all kinds of
circumstances the people who believed in
Newton's theory of the planets and
Newton's theory of gravity had an
anomaly much bigger than the anomaly of
Mercury that was troublesome in the
early days namely the planet Uranus
didn't seem to be moving the right way
and so Adams John couch Adams and the
very a pronoun the planet that's a big
planet that's having gravitational
influences I'm causing this distortion
of the Uranus's orbit
and they could calculate what it would
take where would have to be how big it
would have to be they told astronomers
look for that and they found it the
general relativity was so good to
predict the orbiter these changes in the
orbit orbit of mercury doesn't mean that
it's I'm not even sure with the
interpretation I mean it doesn't mean
the Dark Matter calls for another theory
it could vary I would argue on the
contrary that there is it's not just one
observation that there's a deficit of
mass in certain circumstances there are
many many different kinds of
observations in different circumstances
all of which are coherent with the
possibility that there's a new kind of
particle that makes this Dark Matter I
even think I know what the particle is
something called an axiom this great
theory of general relativity and ok so
general undoubtedly is a it has
limitations but another thing that I
would point out is that it's a theory
that's very simply formulated the idea
that you should explain something simple
in terms of something very complicated I
think is a little wrongheaded moreover
there are quantitative calculations that
relate the strength of the
electromagnetic weak and strong
interactions to the coupling to the
strength of gravity quantitative
relations that indicate that they all
come together so they all can be treated
on the same footing as fundamental
forces and I think I would need a lot of
persuading to ignore that circumstantial
evidence
gravity do I believe it's a fundamental
force absolutely and I think that the
majority of the physicists do consider
it to be a fundamental force we have not
succeeded so far in unifying it with the
other three fundamental forces it
doesn't mean that a solution is not
possible but the problem with gravity is
that first of all in our daily
experience is such a weak force that we
really didn't need to bother with it
until relatively recently in the in the
history of scientific endeavor and the
other difficulty we have since
Einstein's theory came about in the
early 20th century is the unification of
gravity with the quantum theory we don't
have a theory of quantum gravity there
are two regimes where gravity is
extremely important and it's not the
weak force that we can ignore or neglect
in our experiment and that is at the
moment the universe calls on the Big
Bang inflation and a similar system of
beta the collapse of a very massive star
into one point in both cases if you
follow general relativity to the dot you
end up with a singularity which is a
very exotic mysterious object that quite
likely is not physically there is a
mathematical solution but but not
physically there so in those two cases
it becomes imperative that we try to
understand what what the force of
gravity is and that motivates our effort
in into a theory of everything a theory
of quantum gravity and so on
[Music]
[Music]